the legislative session convening for a
special session tonight after not
getting a deal done on the state's
budget now some ground rules for special
sessions Republican Governor Joe
Lombardo sets the agenda anything left
out cannot be discussed during that
session and they usually only last maybe
a day or so but they can go for a
maximum of 20 days so that leaves
everybody asking what about the A's well
multiple sources confirming to politics
now host John langler who was just in
Carson City that a special session for
the stadium bill could happen as early
as tomorrow morning now for reference a
special session was also needed to
finalize the deal for Allegiant Stadium